c'est dans la douleur que l'équipe de
trappes s'est imposé hier face au paris
ca et pourtant le match avait mal débuté
mené tout au long de la rencontre par
l'équipe adverse les trappistes ont tenu
bon on a de la fierté c'est une belle
victoire on revient deux fois au score
ça pour qu'on a un mental on a des
choses à corriger mais c'est
encourageant pour la suite ça prouve
qu'on s'est pas foulé ces on revient
deux fois au score rapidement on se met
nez on a une belle équipe un bon mental
et ça va nous servir pour leur saison
et c'est grâce à cette force et cette
cohésion d'équipé que le strap a pu
revenir au score à la dernière minute du
temps réglementaire et ensuite maîtrisé
cette séance de tirs au but enfin ceux
qui devaient hrk car façon jeu on a été
patient et arraché deux désignations en
fait en bout de course parce qu'on l'a
pas lâché que c'est bon esprit qui va
évidemment quoi ils connaîtront leurs
futurs adversaires pour le prochain tour
de la coupe de france mardi 27 septembre
à 18 heures en attendant le strap se
focalise sur le championnat de pêche